this is a Fox News Alert Elon Musk has
provided Matt taibi of sub stack with
thousands apparently thousands and
thousands of internal documents at
Twitter and they're coming out as we
speak we've told you this several times
those documents prove among other things
the Biden campaign and the DNC directed
Twitter to censor users and Twitter
complied and did this in the critical
final days of the 2020 election cycle in
order and they say this in their emails
to get Joe Biden elected they did the
bidding of a political party and of
elected officials in Washington which is
illegal to get Biden like they rigged
the information available about that
election
that would include the former Twitter
general counsel Jim Baker was a key
player at the FBI during the Russia
collusion house who's overseeing the
censorship there just minutes ago Elon
Musk wrote on Twitter quote if this
isn't a violation of the Constitution's
First Amendment what is
there's so much here other documents
just posted by TB minutes ago reveal
that Twitter's hacked materials policies
was never a real justification for
Banning the New York Post reporting on
Hunter Biden's laptop and they knew it
under Twitter's own stated rules they
would need quote official law
enforcement finding of a hack to invoke
that policy says taibi
this is just one part of the Twitter
files they're apparently going to come
out over a period of dates we will see
but one of the things we've learned
already
is that Twitter under pressure from
Democrats
deleted a tweet from the legendary actor
James Woods who head straight Outside
the Lines by criticizing Hunter Biden
the DNC told this before the last
election told Twitter to take it down
and so they did
James Woods joins us now by phone
James Woods are you there yes I am
Tucker so nice to talk to you it's great
to talk to you I vaguely remember when
your Tweet was pulled down you of course
remember it did you suspect at the time
it was pulled down at the direct request
of the Democratic National Committee
I'm not surprised at all I'm shocked uh
the way any other American would be if
he were a target of a presidential
candidate and a major political party
but here's why I'm not shocked Georgia
you may uh Chuck you may be surprised to
know that there was a lawsuit a while
back a woman accused me of saying that
she gave a Nazi salute and it was a
whole bunch of of stuff about it on
Twitter and I didn't I actually asked
why would somebody say that about her
without going into the details of that
lawsuit it turned out that the DNC was
behind that I won the lawsuit in federal
court
I wasn't reported very much I've been a
target of these people for six years
they have destroyed my career they have
destroyed my livelihood they've
destroyed my faith in a country that my
family has defended uh in the military
since the Revolutionary War I'm about to
be inducted into sons of the American
Revolution and the sons of Revolution
um uh I I cannot I I you're catching me
a bit off guard because I literally just
walked in the door and my wife said have
you seen your phone I was at the firing
range believe it or not practicing for
you I write them to the Second Amendment
which I guess now that I don't have any
First Amendment rights anymore I'm glad
that I still have some Second Amendment
right I think the whole thing is
astonishing I'm just I'm I'm for the
first time in my life honestly
speechless well it is astonishing as you
just pointed out civil laws used
extensively by the left to really Crush
people on the right Alex Jones just had
a billion dollar settlement against him
because he said something that he didn't
hurt anybody he said something people
didn't like
and they wrecked his life and the lives
of many other people and they tried to
wreck yours is there some kind of legal
or civil recourse that you would have
against the people who violated your
first amendment rights
I can guarantee you one thing more than
anything else you'll ever hear in your
life
I will be getting a lawyer I will be
suing the Democratic National Committee
no matter what whether I win or lose I
am going to stand up for the rights that
every American not
a so-called celebrity
I'm not a celebrity but I'm hardly
recognizable anymore because my career
has been destroyed by these very people
and I will too and I'm hoping other
people will do and if it turns out there
are a lot of us on this list where the
dnc's targeted us and I will quote The
Immortal words of Joseph Welch when he
attacks
Joe McCarthy for the enemies list he had
at long laughter have you no shame
yes President Biden all of your
sassy little operative in the DNC who
have targeted American citizens have you
Mr President have all of you at last no
shame
yeah and of course the answer is no they
don't have shame but we we will be
following that and and there may be more
clearly they were fixated on you which I
hope you take as a compliment but also
propels you forward to bring Justice I
think it is a compliment but you know
it's a big price to pay it's not a lot
of fun I I I loved my career for 50
years I was happy to be an award-winning
and honored and appreciated actor and I
missed my career and these people took
it from me and they'll pay a price later
in my life you know but I have to say
um I am not going to take it sitting
down I think these people are Vermin for
doing this to other people
let's not talk about me for a moment
let's talk about just simple individuals
who
put it on a tweet and now their lives
are destroyed you know casting directors
literally in my business literally go
online and they check every actor who
comes in for a part to see who they're
following if an actor or an actress is
following me they will Blacklist them
all right it's about time this is torn
open and I will tell you this it's not
just me but if you take the thousands of
people that I'm sure they did this to
and you got a class action suit
uh they might not be so happy about that
they really are in trouble right now I
think I think this will be something
that will
they're not going to be happy about in
the long run and you know what am I
going to get out of I don't know but I'm
going to stoop for the look there was a
guy who called me a cocaine addict on
on Twitter one never done drugs in my
life and they even stipulated well he
was just doing it was hyperbole I sued
him I won that suit I won the slap
judgment on that suit so you can't talk
about it because of the settlement that
we did much more than that and someone
said why would you do it I said
I would have been my name I'm not gonna
let them blur slander me like this that
was liable in that case but uh there's a
distinction as you know but I'm not
going to put up with it and if I have to
be the flag bearer for this then so be
it I'll be proud to do it
um you should be proud
I want to say in closing you may notice
that I never talked to the Press anymore
I'm asking yes every day okay I've left
Twitter as my only source of of uh you
know of the public any statement I might
might make because obviously those are
my words you're not gonna you know
you're not gonna alter it by doing a
slow motion video of me in black and
white and all that crap that they do
but but they've they've been doing this
as a Jihad against conservative people I
was blocked on Twitter for eight months
you know I was suspended for
quoting Ralph Waldo Emerson
can you imagine that's how crazy these
people are and one of the things that I
said on Twitter once that has become
kind of a meme scratch the liberal and
you'll find a fascist every time let me
tell you these Democrats and now I can
say it because they are no my enemy they
declared this not me
but when they
go around calling everybody all this
ones are Fascist and so you know the
fascists are scratch a liberal and you
will find a fascist every time
every time
well I'm you know I realize you you
don't want to do television interviews
but you are always welcome on this show
because that's one of the most amazing
conversations I've had in a while I mean
I'm I'm really grateful that we reached
you tonight I'm sorry I'm I'm kind of a
pardon of metaphor shooting from the hip
because I
I'd like to know if I put the ranger up
and I was in the rain up in Lopez Canyon
there's not even reception there I I
looked at my phone I literally had
hundreds of them well what the what's
going on and uh so I I can't speak about
this as with with the informed consent
that I would like to and I can't speak
as intelligently as I would like to but
you know when you see your name on an
enemies list
you want to say to your enemies you know
really an interesting thing when you
declare somebody your enemy they can now
say you're my enemy too and it's the
funny thing about the Constitution you
know I I tweeted something today about
James Monroe you know how old James
Monroe president United States by the
way later on you know how old he was
when um when when they signed the
Declaration of Independence no
he was 18 years old
18 years old okay John Adams was 19
years old you know I talked about all
these old white men wrote the
Constitution they were teenagers
fighting for an independent way of life
fighting for right the most precious of
which the most precious of which
was the right to free speech
and the government of the United States
conspired to take my free speech
and throw it in the gutter
and there's something that they should
bear more than anything they have ever
imagined in their wildest dreams the
most dangerous man to these corrupt vile
vermin
is an American
who's not afraid of him and Joe Biden
and all those rats who work with you at
the DNC
to close down my speech
I am not afraid of you
and I'm coming for you
amazing what do you think of Elon Musk
so far
well without a young musk Hunter Biden
would still be
and I can't say this because I don't
know the fact but it seems like he's
been involved in some
pretty interesting chicanery on behalf
of the big guy whoever that may be
we don't know for sure so I don't like
to say things I'm not sure of
but you know I I
think Elon Musk has
very possibly
very possibly
babe America I think the ship of state
has been on a course rivaling the
Titanic and I think what Elon Musk has
done is spend a lot of money like I did
in that lawsuit against the guy who lied
about me you know you spend the money
and say I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
because it's so important to my
survival and my well-being
and I think Elon Musk
loves this country
it's clear that he does why would he
spend all that money on Twitter
rat infested
apps you know why would you do that
unless you could see its value you have
to understand something
you know back back when they had the
power in Twitter the Democrats were
happy to say well it's a private site
it's not it's not like it's the Town
Square you know they can say whatever
they want question they're not seeing it
now that that Elon Musk don't do
but it was in fact
the Town Square it was in fact a forum
for free speech and if you have a Town
Square or only some people are allowed
to use it
then you don't really have a free
country we know in this country what it
was like when certain citizens weren't
allowed to speak when they had to step
off the sidewalk because a person with
different skin color was walking down
the street
you know and I'm not going to compare
anything to what black people in America
went through uh because there's there is
no comparison
there's no comparison
but it's uh I
okay
James Woods I I don't know what to say
other than thank you thank you for
coming on thank you for explaining that
and congratulations on your Vindication
I hope we see you soon
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight